[Musique]
ce n'est pas le rythme les fabricants
d'instruments miss traditionnel la
région c'est bien seulement les utiliser
dans des malles ya lui fait le hawk eye
on lui fait le relais le piqué est le
s'activent le métier en fin de compte et
nb milieu qu'on aime la vie un pays avec
des trois marmailles après c'est
véritablement servier grand monde m'a
reconnu dans à peu près il ya deux ans
un bon 20 ans
ces livres itable mollahs dans la malle
aux passions pour le kayamb en fin de
compte il faut des iphone a le pied
comme parce qu'il faisait le pied comme
dans le fleuve
on aura par exemple un gros ouf le on
aura beau fessier cepsa m'habiller trois
arrêtés là on fera ce qu'on admire sa
greffe d'un format raw grain canal
bichique et c'est la même chose au fin
de compte il ya 25 ans et noah et parce
qu'il y ait bien rond et ça ne colle pas
ligue compte d'ici le ban
hallett et alico ici le plus à cannes
effet le sont ils soient tendres le
cheap chic c'est ça